est ce qu'il ya eu des demandes de fans
un peu particulière mois pendant qu'on
m'a demandé
face à une jeune femme pour ses 40 ans
elle voulait mois en cadeau ouais ouais
vous votre personne quoi panon elle
voulait ma présence en fait j'étais en
haut de l'escalier c'est tout et est
donc ce arrivé et j'ai descendu
l'escalier mais vous y êtes allé parce
qu'ils avaient un peu hein
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'était combien de zéros fait
quelques-uns quelques-uns des risques
que vous avez des demandes de fans un
peu dingue mais y en a un qui était une
sorte de fétichiste des pieds à g et en
fait j'ai dit c'est une photo en fait
qui a déclenché sa sa folie au pied une
photo avec lui envoyer mais cette focale
eric wedge à partir de la révocation
on met les pieds sont que c'est moi les
filles je suis très attentif a les pieds
ah ouais bah c'est rédhibitoire dans les
petits oignons tout manger là à
seulement je les deux pieds au japon
indique le bout des doigts de pied c'est
vrai mais qu un mec un mec au collège
qu'on appelait crottes de nez il
ils mangeaient ses pieds mais il était
très souple alors déjà oui m'enfin c'est
surtout qu'ils s'étaient cpie qu'il
fallait aller tuba ligne pendant des
mois et des mois
toutes les semaines m'envoyer une lettre
en me disant je veux une photo de vos
pieds je veux une fouille les faits bah
non parce que jamais de la vie
les pieds bon ça va marcher
[Rires]
moi j'ai des choses super du phoque mais
vraiment souvent mais y en a 1 depuis
depuis quelques mois depuis touche pas à
mon poste qui en fait me propose de
l'argent mais pour que je le tape ont
forcé un nom ça paye la prostitution
je pense qu'il est un peu vous savez
peut-être un peu se souvenir ou quoi
ouais il veut que je lui marche dessus
avec des talons que je donne des gifles
et me propose de vous appeler la police
[Rires]
j'étais très gênée et voulait pas le
faire mais ça va pas non c'est qu'il
n'ya que vous de choses anormales
non je crois ça normal mais c'est une
des choses qui existent depuis voilà
peut-être ne sera pas pour calmer un
maxi qu'est ce qui vous a demandé de
nouveaux risques sur son plateau à paris
non parce que j'ai cru qu'un des époux
que je le talk non non non
moi jamais suivi un reportage ou en fait
70 en angleterre et donc c'était une
maison une sorte de maison oui je les ai
vus jouer à wii en fait ce sont des
hommes alors souvent des hommes
d'affaires jean cac 40 c'est qu'ils
venaient pour mettre des couches se
faire talk et et bien c'est bien posté
il ya deux mois dans un grand parc
d'attractions j'avais souvent le
week-end pour me payer une bonne tranche
de rire à mon avis vous avez réellement
pour milk et non mais bien sûr c'était
pas ça la vanne en fait je n'ai jamais
parlé dessus quand je me promène
tranquillement et là il ya un couple
quarantaine d'années qui viennent mes
gars me voit et la femme me demande de
faire prendre en photo à côté d'elle
quand elle se place à côté de moi
généralement elle met en met les mains
sur les épaules sauf que là sa main
s'est déplacé directement sur mes fesses
ou alors je n'ai rien dit parce que ça
faisait longtemps qu il parte et elle
revient trois quatre minutes plus tard
elle me voit au fond elle me donne son
numéro de chambre elle n'invite elle son
mari à la rejoindre pendant la nuit vous
me connaissez
bah ouais vite et vous avez pas été j'ai
du bon tabac bien sûr évidemment